so as we get into Batman endgame what I
want to do here is take a second to
rehash a couple things about death of
the family since there seem to be a
little confusion but what I also want to
let you guys know is that we're going to
split Batman in-game up into several
parts and the reason why is because
Batman endgame has some information that
is paramount to future stories regarding
Batman especially once we get to Jim
Gordon Batman but also because there's
so many things that happen in this story
that it's almost impossible to do it
justice over the course of a single
video
so again touching back on death of the
family this story wasn't so much about
the physical deaths of the bad family as
it was about their metaphorical deaths
what I mean here is that in the eyes of
the Joker Batman had begun progressively
weaker over the years due to the fact
that he came to rely on the bat family
and a physical and emotional way
physically the bat family was able to
aid Batman and taking down various
criminals or simply facing overwhelming
odds emotionally that that family
provided a support net for Bruce Wayne
in his times of dire need for the Joker
however he always stood alone if we go
back and we look at all of his schemes
in relation to Bruce Wayne while
characters like Harley Quinn played a
major role in his life and were villains
like two-face Riddler in penguin would
sometimes be contacted for the
implementation of these schemes in the
end we can always remove these elements
from the Joker and he could still
function adequately and be just as
dangerous in his eyes Batman wasn't this
way the shooting of Barbara Gordon
during The Killing Joke and the death of
Jason Todd during the death in the
family story had massive emotional
impacts on Batman in that for the first
time he truly understood the danger that
comes with having sidekicks and putting
them in harm's way however rather than
casting aside the notion and functioning
as a solo act from that point going
forward each time Batman gained a new
sidekick his emphasis was to ensure
their safety even if it meant
sacrificing his desire to achieve his
own goals and to the Joker this had
removed the cunning and dark edge from
Batman and instead of returning to his
roots as they do whatever it takes
antihero the Joker came to believe that
Batman's moral code had made him soft in
an effort to rectify this the Joker
implemented the events taking place in
death of the family as a way to destroy
the bat family's trust in Batman and if
at all possible kill them while the
story showed us that Batman was
successfully able to keep the bat family
alive the Joker's plan was ultimately
successful in that the rest of the bat
family had simply lost their trust in
Bruce Wayne due to the fact that he had
kept important information from them in
the form of the Joker having previously
accessed the Batcave and possibly
learning their identities
now in terms of in-game this story
actually concludes Scott Snyder series
involving the return of the Joker and
continues a Joker scheme to destroy
Bruce Wayne's relationship with his
allies by targeting the Justice League
and turning them against Batman as
something I'd also like to touch on here
is Batman eternal while Batman eternal
takes place between death of the family
in endgame it doesn't really have
anything to do with the Joker
instead this story centers on a villain
named Thomas Eliot also known as hush
who launches a massive campaign to
bankrupt Bruce Wayne something he's
successful in doing in addition to this
someone I'd like to draw your attention
to as it pertains to our discussion on
endgame is Julia pennyworth the
estranged daughter of Alfred during the
events of Batman eternal Alfred had been
attacked by hush around the same time
that Julia had been discovered by Bruce
Wayne in Hong Kong during his efforts to
stop carmine Falcone who was working
alongside hush while Julie and Batman
were able to work together to defeat
Thomas Eliot carmine Falcone and the
rest of their group during their time
together Batman discovered Julia
pennyworth identity and introduced her
to Alfred while their introduction was a
little tenuous due to the fact that
Julia had abandonment issues with Alfred
recovering from his injuries and with
Julia looking to understand more about
her father Scott Snyder rolled her
character over into endgame to operate
as someone that could both tend to
Alfred and help Bruce Wayne and future
conflicts with a possibility existing
that she could become a permanent member
of the Batman family
so the events of Batman endgame pickup
with someone having apparently gassed
the entire city of Gotham while there
are various news agencies in such
reporting on the events what we'll find
is that this is a prelude of sorts in
that according to the news reports the
gas itself appears to be harmless and
was designed to send the citizens into
panic and vacate the area under this
logic the belief is at the abandoned
section of Gotham operates as an arena
of sorts and so transitioning to Batman
in his battle armor we find him
addressing an unnamed foe as they appear
to be either attacking Batman personally
or else attacking the city of Gotham now
at this point we jump back around 20
minutes before this incident with Batman
fighting various villains and dying in
the process now who these villains are
isn't particularly important for this
story what is important though is why
Bruce Wayne is experiencing this what we
learn is that this is actually a dream
to sidetrack for a second during the
events of Batman eternal Bruce Wayne was
exposed to the fear toxin of scarecrow
and while it was initially believed that
this was a run-of-the-mill toxin during
endgame we actually learned that this
toxin differs from its normal version
and that is referred to as the Cassandra
strain and forces its victim to
experience their deaths in a manner
similar to a dream but causes them to
wake up at the moment before they die
now this is particularly important
because what this will do is play a key
role in Batman's life as he experiences
the forthcoming events now following
this we join Bruce Wayne alongside
Alfred and Julia as they engage in small
talk regarding fallout from the events
of quarter vowels night of the owls
death of the family and Batman eternal
all of which have led to the
implementation of a new monitoring
system that would allow Bruce Wayne to
locate crimes as they take place in the
city of Gotham however in the mists of
their conversation Wonder Woman suddenly
attacks Batman something I'd like you to
notice here is that Bruce Wayne
immediately attaches mental disks on the
side of her head now again this is
actually very important because this
will play a role in Wonder Woman's
defeat at the hands of that man but
while Bruce tries to understand the
situation Wonder Woman simply states
that for the longest time the Justice
League had been intending to kill Batman
now while Scott Snyder doesn't
necessarily state
I would surmise that this is really a
tip of the hat to the events that took
place in the Tower of Babel where racial
Ghul had used Batman's information on
the weak points of the various Justice
League members to defeat them all in
turn again this is largely unsaid but
the fallout of the event saw the league
losing trust in Batman and questioning
whether or not he was an asset or a
liability due to the fact that for all
intents and purposes he had been
collecting on information that he could
use to presumably defeat them at some
point in time but regardless because
Wonder Woman is so powerful and because
Bruce Wayne has nothing to help him but
his wits and his communication systems
with Alfred and Julia he instructs them
to enact plan Fenrir which was the
reason why the gas was released at the
start of this story now jumping back to
the present moment with Bruce Wayne and
his battle armor his description of
Wonder Woman is of stupendous importance
the reason why is because how she acts
here is the same way that the rest of
the Justice League will act during her
encounter with Bruce Wayne as he
describes her her movements and thinking
are completely fluid meaning that she's
not acting against her will while Bruce
doesn't know why this is happening what
he does know is that Wonder Woman is
pulling no punches and legitimately
intends to kill him and so while Bruce
recognizes that he has to give her as
all in this fight this requires him to
walk a kind of tightrope and that he has
to fight her hard enough to overcome
Wonder Woman but not so hard that he
actually kills her in addition to this
Bruce's attempt to find out why she's
fighting hammer answered in riddles with
replies that maybe Bruce Wayne brought
this on himself and maybe this is
something that was going to happen all
along but regardless of what she says
Bruce comes to the realization that
there does not seem to be a way for him
to break through her mind and so after
coming to the conclusion that the only
way for him to actually defeat Wonder
Woman is to let her believe that she
successfully killed him Batman
activates the mental disks on the side
of her head casting an illusion that
makes her believe that she has killed
Batman however because Wonder Woman had
referenced the Justice League as a whole
with their desire to kill Batman Bruce
contacts Alfred regarding the arrival of
everyone else
but before Alfred can provide Bruce
Wayne with an answer the battlefield is
immediately met with the arrival of the
flash now the conflict between the two
is actually over in a matter of
what Batman tells us is that the suit is
hooked up to a series of servers and
that while they had invested a ton of
money in the system a majority of it
went towards the servers providing an
automated reaction to the Batman armor
that would allow Batman to combat the
flash by knowing where he will be before
Bruce's mind can catch up with what the
flash is doing and so after deploying a
slick substance on the ground the flash
quite literally loses his footing and
slides right into a building presumably
knocking him out or temporarily taking
him out of the conflict now following
this is Aquaman who arrives to confront
Batman after the defeat of Wonder Woman
and the flash because he hails from a
society that prides itself on honor
above all else Aquaman's response is to
fight Bruce Wayne and single combat but
again much like Wonder Woman Aquaman's
considerable strength would allow him to
easily overpower Batman and so in
response to this Bruce deploys a
substance that immerses itself around
Aquaman leaving him unable to move and
so as we learn here this foam is derived
from magnesium carbonate and is designed
to absorb moisture what this means is
that because Aquaman relies on water
stores within his body to keep him
replenished while he's on land should he
struggle or try to break free the foam
substance will absorb more and more
moisture by way of Aquaman's
perspiration leaving him in a weakened
state and possibly even kill him if he
loses too much moisture in his body and
so with the battle between Bruce Wayne
and Aquaman at an end Batman is met with
the arrival of Superman now as Superman
Scott Snyder provides us some measure of
what's going on or at the very least
who's behind all this but we don't
actually learn how it was done while he
doesn't come out and say it the jovial
nature of Superman along with the grins
from the rest of the Justice League
lead Batman to realize that the Joker is
behind these attacks now again this is
probably one of the most important
aspects of not just this story but also
a Batman's history throughout DC Comics
the Joker has largely been isolated to
Gotham as the main antagonist of Batman
and very rarely have we seen him travel
to other cities and deal with other
heroes while stories like Emperor Joker
dealt with his arrival in Metropolis and
battled with Superman there had never
really been an instance where the Joker
had successfully dominated the entire
Justice League what this moment
basically tells us is that the danger of
the
Joker isn't isolated to Batman and
instead the Joker himself poses
legitimate threat to the world as a
whole
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and in the
next video we're going to pick up with
our battle with Batman as Superman as
well as the fallout and the Batman's
first encounter with the Joker after he
had regained his normal face with that
being said I will catch you guys later
purse